[Musique]
merci monsieur c'est pour moi
j'ai l'impression d'avoir déjà vu ça pas
la note 1 d'avoir déjà vu cette scène
est pourtant promis c'est la première
fois que je mets les pieds sur cette
terrasse est peut-être passé dans une
autre dimension non joie sur l
impression d'avoir déjà vécu une scène
est un phénomène tout à fait courant ça
nous arrive à tous c'est là dedans que
ça se passe quelle est l'origine de
cette drôle de sensation comme ans
explique-t-elle on se retrouve dans
l'atelier je vous explique tout et ça
c'est du jamais vu sur youtube
le déjà vu c'est donc cette sensation
d'avoir déjà vécu une action qui se
déroule à l'instant présent alors qu'en
réalité cet événement est totalement
inédit les scientifiques appellent ce
phénomène par amnésie parra pour accoter
naisy pour mémoire est littéralement à
côté de la mémoire autrefois les gens
voyaient le déjà vu comme un fragment de
vie antérieure qui re surgi dans le
présent le phénomène est connu depuis
longtemps mais jusqu'en 1876 il n'a pas
de nom c'est le philosophe français
emile boire ac qui le baptise il propose
l'expression déjà vu dans son livre
l'avenir des sciences psychique elle
convient à tout le monde à quel point
que les anglo saxons la reprenne telles
qu'elles sont à traduire le vin rouge le
tour eiffel l'a déjà vous le déjà vu je
vous vu tu le fait très bien pourtant
personne n'est encore capable à l'époque
d'expliquer ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau en situation de déjà vu c'est un
vrai casse tête pour les scientifiques
ce n'est que bien plus tard au xxème
siècle que l'on finit par comprendre que
ce phénomène est probablement liée au
fonctionnement de l'année noire
vous le savez notre cerveau est
constitué de dizaines de milliards de
neurones qui sont reliés entre eux et
qu'ils forment un réseau ce réseau est
comparable à une carte routière on
trouve une multitude de route et les
circuits neuronaux ceux ci traverse et
relie différentes aires du serbe pour
qu'un souvenir soit mémoriser il doit
emprunter un circuit neuronal qui passe
à travers de nombreuses zones du cerveau
tu m'as perdu là j'ai déjà oublié le
début pas de panique c'est normal plus
un souvenir à deux on a traversé plus il
ya de chances qu'ils soient modifiés ou
altéré en cours de route heureusement
notre cerveau à la parade il dispose de
divers checkpoint ce sont des zones de
contrôle qui servent à vérifier que tout
fonctionne bien l'une d'elles est très
importante c'est l'hippocampe
une hippocampe oui on l'appelle comme ça
à cause de sa forme elle est proche de
celle de ce petit poisson qui a une tête
de cheval cette structure joue un rôle
essentiel c'est l'un des sièges de la
mémoire c'est l'endroit où les souvenirs
à court terme sont transformés en
souvenir à long terme qui sont ensuite
stockés ailleurs l'hippocampe est donc
capable de créer de nouveaux souvenirs
mais aussi de faire remonter ce qui sont
déjà stockées il y passe des quantités
d'informations tellement que parfois ça
se bouscule et comme un ordinateur
l'hippocampe peu buggé tenez par exemple
il lui arrive de recevoir un souvenir
sans contenu parce qu'apres parle de
souvenirs vide c'est un peu comme
recevoir un courrier
et découvrir qu'il n'ya rien à
l'intérieur absolument et c'est
précisément ce phénomène qui serait à
l'origine du sentiment de déjà vu comme
si l'hippocampe considérer que ce que
vous vivez à l'instant t les images les
sensations est un souvenir alors que ça
n'en est pas un d'ailleurs lorsqu'on
demande aux personnes victimes de ce
phénomène de préciser où et quand ils
ont déjà vécu leurs derniers déjà vu ils
en sont incapables tenez essayez de vous
souvenir du contenu de votre dernier
déjà vu
ça me revient pas normal puisque ce
souvenir n'a jamais existé il est
impossible de s'en rappeler bon si vous
ne vous souvenez pas de cette
explication il existe une autre
hypothèse elle a été mise en lumière en
2007 une équipe de chercheurs a
découvert que la sensation de déjà-vu
étaient peut-être liées au
fonctionnement d'une autre zone impliqué
dans le circuit de la mémoire le cortex
frontal
cortex désigne la couche de neurones à
la surface du cerveau quant au cortex
frontal il désigne cette zone en rouge
situé juste derrière le front c'est une
zone essentielle dans la prise de
décision et c'est à ce titre qu'elle
serait impliqué dans la sensation de
déjà
imaginez comme moi tout à l'heure sur la
terrasse vous pénétrez dans un
environnement inconnu qui vous semblent
famille vous êtes peut être victime de
ce que l'on appelle un conflit de
mémoire un conflit entre ce que vous
êtes en train de vivre est ce que vous
pensez avoir déjà mais à cet instant
votre cortex frontal serait tout
simplement en train d'analyser votre
mémoire pour prendre une décision
est ce un vrai ou un faux souvenirs je
n'essaie pas jamie le déjà-vu serait
donc la notification que votre cerveau
vérifie le bon fonctionnement de votre
mémoire
vu la tête qu'il faut foin si cela vous
arrive pas de panique ce petit bug n'est
pas très grave toutefois chez certaines
personnes souffrent décrite ci il semble
que ce soit un symptôme assez courant
l'épilepsie est une affection
neurologique qui se manifeste par des
décharges brusque d'influx nerveux dans
le cerveau or pour certains patients la
sensation de déjà-vu pourrait être
annonciatrice d'une crise la région
responsable de cette sensation chez les
épileptiques serait la région finale
située juste sous leopard grand merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette vidéo qui
je l'espère restera bien gravé dans
votre mémoire et vérifier que vous êtes
abonné vous pensez lettre déjà mais ce
n'est peut-être pas le cas à très
bientôt et les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux le déjà vu vous vu
pourtant personne n'est encore capable
je reprends on la refait mais oui oui
attendait
[Applaudissements]